good morning belief nation today's  messages chase your dreams over to you  Sachin Tendulkar something which is  really really important is which I  believed you have to chase your dreams  dreams do come true I've changed one for  the last 21 years one one cup for India  after 21 years so dreams do come true it  may take a bit longer than some but but  they do come true sometimes what happens  that we push ourselves but not enough  because we try and then we say we find  excuses we say that all enough I've  tried it's not happening and you give up  and one extra step success is waiting  for you which you sometimes don't end up  taking so always be prepared to push  yourself so the question the day today  is do you push yourself enough leave it  in the comments below I'll join the  discussion thank you so much for  watching have an amazing day continue to  believe I'll see you again tomorrow  morning for another shot events press  espresso amigo